Join our weekly Amazon Giftcard Giveaway
All you have to do is be subscribed to our channel like this video and leave a comment about today's topic
We will choose winners randomly from the comments section
Hey guys the seventh season finally arrived and its premiere letter
So speechless a theory that I introduced to its a few months ago
and in my last video came true
Aryeh start where voters face to set up a huge meeting that attended all important phrase and killed every last one of them with a
Poison which as I said those foreshadowed back in the fourth season
While there are plenty of important scenes that happened in this episode which I will break down in the upcoming days today
I will break down the recently released preview for the second episode
Daenerys was born on dragonstone valve a storm raged and for this reason
She's sometimes called the near storm born storm born is also the title the second episode of the seventh season which is another
Title named after Daenerys and her home as the season premiere is named Dragonstone
Preview starts with John Royce the Lord of Runestone and the Powerful Bannerman of house lorraine stating that the targaryen cannot be trusted
And as you probably guessed the queen of dragons will send
Invitation to the King in the North End other nodes and lords to come and meet her at Dragonstone
Daenerys is
Annotation along with Sam's letter in which she states that there's plenty of dragonglass on Dragonstone
Island the lead-up severs and John's known to live interval for dragonstone placed on with John and Daenerys so meet for the very first time
Even though John snows main intention will not be to meet Daenerys
But rather to collect as much dragon glass as he can then we have a shot of circe's saying
The Mad King daughter will Destroy the realm
The Matte finish trying to even the odds and she will try to persuade other important people to support her rather than the nearest
Targaryen well there will be a huge meeting in winterfell once again there will also be a huge meeting in Dragonstone
as you can see Daenerys will have a huge meeting in which you'll plan the conquest of westeros with her advisers and allies in the
Main hole in the castle of Dragonstone now we come to the most exciting shot of this preview
Which is the Chateau fires dire wall cimmeria the shut official confirmed that caravelle finally?
Reunited for direwolf that you forced to leave in the very first season that she was afraid for her
Direwolf's well-being which was the consequence of nemedia protecting aria from the Prince Joffrey Baratheon by biting Joffrey's Arm
Now that we know that aria will reunited for die role in my opinion
There's a high possibility that this same direwolf will reunite with Aria by saving her life this prediction of mine
Is simply a result of considering the jump Dolph mostly appeared in crucial?
Moments such as saving the Lord commanders live by whining at the door
Saving Sam's life from a bite and giving a chance to the Lord commander to destroy the white with fire
Helping to kill the wildlings during the battle of castle black and also defending John's body
With all of this being said I think that the Mira's appearance will be nothing less but glorious
Namira will appear and save Arya once again in description for the second episode there stated that Daenerys receives
unexpected visitor whom she probably meets in this particular shot an
Unexpected visitor is most likely no Sandra's we got to see her in dragonstone in the first official trailer of the seventh season
There's also a shot of Jon
Snow slamming littlefinger against the wall similar as ned did back in the first season
But let's hope jon will not end up manipulated and betrayed
Let's hope jon will learn from his family's mistake as sense that pointed out. He should in today's episode
There are also a few shots of a huge fleet battle that will result it a lot of casualties for Denny's allies in the following
days
I will surely bring you numerous theories and predictions
Based on the first episode of the seventh season and as always let me know your opinion about all of this in the comment section
Down below, I hope you guys enjoyed this video if you did please make sure to subscribe to our channel
And I hope to see in the next peace
you